okay
I have a good science test
reminders
trying to learn
yeah
can you confirm that you can hear Us
online
testing one two three
okay but will we be able to hear them
online one day
question
uh yeah explain talked earlier
okay great yeah and is um is Steve
betric out there
he sure is
okay so we have the whole Community here
are you ready to go yes I am okay
well good why don't we go ahead and get
started welcome everyone
yeah actually this is pretty good for a
turnout lately in terms of our in-person
conferences but it's great to see
everyone here and I don't know how many
people are online
anyways
um so today is a
demise conference
um that we normally have on Thursdays uh
over the lunch hour but uh people defend
uh Theses and dissertations it's
sometimes at a different time and so
today
um we have the thesis defense I think
this is the last of our graduates from
this year
um
who all have been fixtures in the
department and now a bunch of them are
leaving but that's supposed to be what
happens anyway some so
um uh the committee is all here I
welcome the committee and
um the usual process for those um who
might not come to these on a regular
basis is that the candidate doing their
defense gives their presentation the
public asks questions the public is
dismissed leaving behind the
um
many they may ask further questions and
then the candidate is dismissed and the
committee decides if the
student has successfully defended their
thesis so um it gives me great pleasure
today to introduce someone who has been
one of the many fixtures around the
department for uh quite some time and
um
Mina Mishra is a fifth year PhD student
in the health and clinical informatics
major of the program she's also been a
National Library of Medicine fellow
which is how most of our PhD students
are funded on our t-15 training Grant
before starting the PHD program she
worked as a certified clinical research
professional managing and coordinating
clinical trials and oncology and bone
marrow transplant I remember her telling
me about that when she came for her
interview
she has a master's degree in
biotechnology from Banaras Hindu
University in Varanasi India and she
also received an mph from the University
of South Carolina before moving to the
Northwest her interests involve using
real world data that generate high
quality evidence secondary uses of
electronic health record data for
research and clinical decision support
improving informatics infrastructure for
enabling the learning Health System
system and Health Data standards and
interoperability she's also a member of
the m3c the national covid cohort
collaborative Education and Training
working group and our current research
involves data accessibility and quality
uses quality issues focused on opioid
use disorder risk assessment I was
delighted to hear when she told me this
not too long ago that she actually will
be moving on to a new role as a
biomedical informatics research
specialist with the Oxnard Health System
I believe that's in New Orleans right
yes okay that would be great and she
will hope to continue research
collaborations with people here at OHSU
and in the n3c community so I will
um let Mina take it from here and if
there's any problems with the online
speak up and let us know
sure
um thank you Bill for a fine
introduction and thank you everybody for
coming to this presentation defense
so the topic for my research was
defining gaps between information needs
and betterness for assessing opioid use
disorder risk in patient considered for
long-term opioid treatment
this is a road map for this defense
essentially I will introduce you to the
problem that I use to scope my research
and introduce you to the research
framework uh basically aim one two and
three methods and results for each of
the aims and share the conclusion
limitations and future work
so here's a problem that I looked at
when I started my research uh
essentially you know within a period of
10 years quarter of a million people
died in in the United States from
overdose involving prescription opioids
nearly one in four to one in five
patients prescribed opioids misuse it
and one in 10 develop abuse the economic
burden from chronic pain and abuse and
opioid use disorder runs into billions
of dollars
to address this growing epidemic they
have been significant you know laws
policies and guidelines that had been
that have been instantiated over the
years
and since Primary Care Providers take
care of most uh of the chronic pain
patients and account for almost half of
prescription opioids uh the role that
the you know it makes it worthwhile to
look at uh what what are what is the
role of CDC guidelines in addressing
this issue
uh looking at uh the the evidence for
all other laws and regulations I found
there there was a need for adequate data
that the data was not adequate to
understand the exact impact of these
policies on at a patient level and
um CC guidelines uh provided of kind of
a jump start for me to start
investigating uh if how much of a role
displays in addressing uh the the opioid
use disorder
this is essentially the CDC guideline
and I specifically looked at the
arrangement of treatment for opioid use
disorder which is one of the
recommendations by the CDC uh for the
primary care providers who are
prescribing opioids for chronic pain
however in order to arrange treatment
for opioid use disorder the providers
need to identify this in their patient
population
again looking at other significant more
recent
updates there is a huge initiative that
came out in 2018 which is uh helping and
addiction long term and it essentially
asks the scientific Community to make
efforts to
um
understand
pain and improve treatment for pain and
also to understand and prevent
the opioid use disorder better
the national plan for adjusting opioid
misuse
costs for the prescriber and medical
community to make efforts to continue to
evaluate and update prescriber guideline
including the CDC guideline for
prescribing opioids for chronic pain and
standardize the use for anyone who
prescribes the opioids
so there clearly is a role that medical
community and scientific Community plays
in addressing this crisis
however to address the triple aim of
improving care enabling research and
informing policies we need a learning
Health System a system where evidence
flows to practice practice flows to data
and data can create new evidence
this becomes really complex when we are
dealing with a chronic pain and oud as
they are both very complex conditions
plus there is an added layer of
complexity when we run into stigmatized
condition
needing to build trust uh for between
them and the patients provider often do
not document they document variably in
the EHR and as a result there is a need
for an EHR data Readiness framework that
takes into account the real world
challenges of caring for complex
patients with stigmatized conditions
so um I started looking at what are the
different uh Frameworks for
understanding complex patients and I
found that stigma was not mentioned as
one of the constructs basically complex
patients were described around medical
complexity socioeconomic factors mental
illness or patient behaviors but stigma
was missing from the from framework for
describing complex patients
and understanding opioids opioid use
disorder a little bit better it's a
highly heterogeneous condition which
ranges from mild to severe and it's
diagnosed using the recent five criteria
two out of 11
spanning over four different concepts of
impaired control social impairment risky
use and family pharmacological
properties of Tolerance and withdrawal
so purely complex and very fairly
heterogeneous disorder
initial review of literature for
adherence to guidelines suggested that
lack of time and training are
significant barriers for Primary Care
Providers to care for patients on
long-term opioid treatment and educating
providers in opioid risk assessment did
not significantly change the rate of
risk assessment in the actual practice
even though there was an increase in
knowledge and willingness to apply risk
assessment for initiating opioids so
clearly there was a gap
also looking in the literature I found
that it takes on average 17 years to
just 14 percent of the published
literature to be translated to practice
so all these kind of prompted me to
uh Define my research framework around
these three aims so the first aim was to
increase understanding of barriers to
risk assessment and use that for
informing uh the risk the information
need and information Readiness
assessment a developer methodology for
those those two aims and then triangular
triangulate the finding and do an
information Gap analysis and probably
and and provide a set of recommendations
for future informatics projects
so looking at my aim one which was
understanding tasks and barriers so I
knew that the Gap existed didn't know
why so I started my uh my tasks made the
first thing was to increase our
understanding of risk assessment tasks
for CDC guidelines
and determine what the barriers are for
translating the evidence to practice for
oud risk assessment and identify factors
that may affect data in the EHR
here's a bird's eye view of a guideline
component opioid prescribing for chronic
pain in the primary care page setting
ideally when a patient comes in the
clinic the provider is trying to
determine risk versus benefit for
putting a patient on a long-term opioid
treatment
as a result in the Box up on the upper
on the top you see all the various
information systems and tools that the
provider needs to look at
and use in order to make risk for their
patients vitamin risk for their patients
so there is a use of validated screening
tools or questionnaires to determine if
there's the opioid misuse or opioid use
disorder is happening also looking into
the EMR for medical history for science
of opioid risk or average drug related
behaviors looking at the urine drug
screening results for any unexpected
results and also looking in the
prescription prescription drug
monitoring program or pdmp for any signs
of patients
approaching four or more prescriber or
multiple prescriber or multiple
pharmacies that could indicate some
misuse or abuse
so the aim one again the method was to
find from literature all the opioid risk
factors and how they compared with the
what is in the guideline
in order to do so I did a literature
search and the scope for the search was
to include
um in all literature that have opioid
risk assessment elements uh for patients
on long-term prescription opioids for
chronic non-cancer pain I included
literature from PubMed hence Corpus and
primarily the risk assessment elements
that I touched upon in the prior slide
like screening tools pdmp aberrant drug
digital Behavior I scan all those to see
if there are indication of barriers
arising from the use of these different
tools
I use 14 constructs from three
Frameworks for a thematic extraction and
synthesizing my findings so the first
one is
the socio-technical model for health
information technology by City And sync
this framework essentially looks at
barriers using any health information
Health technology in the context of
social technical in the social technical
context in the healthcare setting so
there are different elements in in the
healthcare that may affect
the adoption of a health technology
intervention like people workflow
communication user interface software
Hardware internal internal policies
organizational policies external rules
to name us few so there are eight total
constructs from this framework
uh the second framework I use is the
katana framework which is essentially a
framework that was uh uh developed for
understanding the barriers to Physicians
adherence to practice guidelines and it
uh actually uh calls upon some
behavioral constructs like knowledge
attitude and behavior elements to
adoption of best factors
and the third one was the Paris
framework which essentially defines
successful implementation uh with uh in
the
on the basis of strong evidence or as a
function of strong evidence strong
context and strong facilitation
so clearly there was some overlap
between all these three different
Frameworks but they provided a good
foundation for me to do thematic
extraction and synthesize my finding as
you can see the facilitation from the
Paris framework up on the top uh
actually does include some of the
constructs from the socio-technical
health model for health information
technology like the clinical contact
content which is the EHR or workflow and
communication and things like that and
the context if you can see that that
also overlaps between the three
framework the context on in the Paris
framework overlaps with the people an
internal organization policies and the
people uh you know constantly in turn
overlaps with the knowledge attitude and
behavior so quite a degree of overlap
but that was very good for me to ensure
rigor in the Thematic extraction
so here are the 12 themes that emerged
from 51 studies for barriers to
guideline Concord and oud risk
assessment and I'm not going to go over
each one of them but touch upon the
important ones that actually prompted my
further work
so essentially there was the theme of
variable documentation affecting data
quality
because of of stigma associated with ou
detection leading to variable
documentation and incons consistent
documentation of opioid misuse and abuse
in the EHR there are also variation in
the use and documentation of screening
tools in the EHR and aberrant drug
related behaviors used as indicator of
misuse are inconsistently
unsystematically document documented
uh there are
um themes around
um you know evidence and people also um
and it appears that provider experience
may be playing a role in the real world
decision making because most of the
evidence in the clinical guidelines are
supported by weak uh most of the
recommendations are supported by weak
evidence there is no widely used risk
assessment tool accurately predicting or
identifying misuse and applying the
DSM-5 criteria to patients on long-term
opioid treatment has proven to be
difficult
also level of risk is uh that patient
provider determines for their patient is
determined by the level of trust and
history of knowing the patient so
clearly there is a role for provider
experience in making real world
decisions for the patient population
so the major takeaways from this and for
my next step were again reiterating it
is the task of opioid use disorder risk
assessment is fairly complex and data
heavy providers often triangulate data
from various sources in order to make
decisions about the patient's oud risk
and the absence of strong evidence for
most recommendations providers make
decisions based on the experience and
Associated stigma affect how pcps
document opioid misuse and use and use
disorder
um and this was to maintain patient
provider trust primarily and also to
reduce harm uh because
um you know a patient may lose an
insurance coverage for a potentially
beneficial treatment
so this is just a cartoon showing that
the need uh the provider's information
needs uh maybe due to
um some knowledge some in some cases
knowledge gas but primarily uh maybe due
to the experience that they've gained
from taking care of this patient
population
so these were the questions from my aim
two and three which patient specific
information do providers care Primary
Care Providers find useful in making
decisions about their patients oud risk
and what does the availability and
quality of useful or you do this
Concepts or factors look like in the EHR
in order to address these two goals I
came up with this framework like a
generalized methodology to address these
two goals
um and uh
essentially what I was trying to do is
uh find a gap between information needs
for
um a high high opioid
opioid use disorder risk factors and the
Readiness of the EHR to address that
need
and and if you see the information need
part has two steps identification and
prioritization and the information
Readiness has another two-step
operationalization and assessment so
let's go over what it means
so the methodology for aim to for the
identification steps I essentially
looked into the literature and consulted
Primary Care Providers to identify all
the opioid risk factors there are or and
come up with a carefully picked opioid
risk factors for my Delphi survey in The
Next Step so what I wanted to do is look
at uh and rank high neat High need for
uh for the opioid risk factors in the
real world clinical decision making and
in order to inform future informatics
projects so anti-faction identification
and prioritization involved literature
review and modified Delphi survey to
rank OED risk factors
however before I delve into the
literature review aspect of it and how
complex this the step was uh I needed a
reality check the reality check about
what the opioid use disorder actually
means and the term and how to apply that
for literature um literature finding
literature opioid use disorder is a
fairly new it was it actually was turned
around somewhere around 2013
um and it's another name for addiction
uh the the addiction term has also
evolved over time and it includes
dependence and abuse people with
addiction may also misuse opioids
opioids misuse or abuse does not
necessarily result in addiction but
opioids are highly addicted and the risk
increases with misuse and abuse
um also in the context of the chronic
pain population it's important to
remember that dependence does not
necessarily imply use disorder for
patients or long-term opioid treatment
as they develop dependence from extended
use so in this
um you know found with this knowledge I
conducted by literature search and it
was important to consult the providers
to decide which opioids use risk factors
opioid use disorder risk factors they
would suggest to start my Delphi survey
with
uh so here is all the literature review
I did I essentially using the Search
terms for opioid related Adverse Events
toxicity and disorders uh to collect the
wide range of literature I ended up with
269
um articles
um and after removing articles on
dependence overdose or other facilities
I was left with 25 and then I ended up
adding more from a review of references
of the primary literature as a result I
ended up a 1551 articles with factors
related to misuse abuse addiction opioid
use disorder and the reason I include in
this user views addiction was I wanted
to because they can indicate increased
risk for
um for opioid use disorder addiction
so here is um like a word cloud of all
the risk factors that I ran uh and it as
you can see substance abuse and
Psychiatry
um are on the top so most of the studies
identified these two as a risk factor
for oud uh however there are others like
um and these two factors are also
present in the clinical guidelines but
uh you know factors like pain
catastrophizing or uh you know running
into legal issues or
um
um family history may not be in the
guidelines so uh or are not in in the
guidelines
as a result you know it is essential to
to get all there all I could find and uh
kind of get a consensus on which of
these play a role when they're the
primary care providers are trying to
decide risk for their patients
it's important to note that uh the
literature on this topic and the way
they Define the outcomes in the studies
uh varied a lot so uh they there was a
use of all different kinds of uh outcome
definitions in the studies and most of
them did use a validated screening tool
to Define an outcome and even within the
validated screening tool there was a
variability in what tool was used to
define misuse or abuse
I just wanted to catch up on the
heterogeneity on the about this
literature
um to give you a back a sense of how
complex this is
in the end I ended up uh you know with
the iterative uh private care provider
consultation I ended up starting out
with 57 items for my next step for the
prioritization step uh they spent nine
different behavioral so psychosocial
domains uh demographics substance use
Psychiatry socio-economic pain and
function medication average drug related
behaviors medical homo morbidities and
genetics excuse me and you can see that
the average Behavior address was huge it
was around 16
um elements and items from that topic
so to give you a little bit of
background about Delphi process it's an
iterative survey process where
participants uh are given a
questionnaire uh in multiple rounds of
questions survey takes place uh with the
selected group of participants
um and uh in this the goal is to come to
a consensus
in a full defy survey the first round is
basically a qualitative round where we
collect a broad perspective on a topic
in order to use that to build the
quantitative part of the survey however
for my
process my for my work I substituted the
first round with the in-depth literature
review and uh upfront a primary care
provider input and essentially
eliminated that qualitative round and my
first round was a quantitative round
and I also wanted to kind of understand
the impact of the level of experience uh
on uh
Bank on on consensus if the you know
whether a provider with more experience
May undefy or rank
um uh opioid use disorder differently
than somebody with less experience and
for this I defined three levels of
experts for the survey
so here here's how the survey looked
there are multiple pages of it of course
but just to give you an idea uh each oud
risk factor uh within each domain uh was
ranked by Primary Care Providers on a
likert scale of one to five
um also I I did include uh and identify
the need for a qualitative data if in
case there was something uh you know I
missed or there was some additional
Concepts that may uh um arise from this
survey therefore there was one open
response question on the survey to
collect any addition factors
and um I did I kind of made an attempt
to get a private care providers from a
different
um different types of fabric setting so
they were clinics uh
at oh GSU that were approached and also
clinics in the community I also included
clinics that were that qualified as a
federally qualified Health Centers
so here is the Delphi process and the
Essential Elements of the Delphi process
is defining the consensus up front I
Define my consensus as more than 75
percent of the participants rating and
oud risk factor or concept
within these three categories so if the
concept mapped
fell into the extremely and very useful
category uh and more more than 75
percent of the participant agreed it was
extremely and very useful it the
consensus for that item was supposed was
uh decided to have been met
um and it's essential to know that I did
collapse my five point I could scale to
three point in order to um analyze my
responses
um the second essential part of the
identify survey is the control feedback
so with each subsequent around in each
subsequent survey uh we uh provide the
participant with the aggregate response
from the first round in this case I
provided with them with a median for
each opioid use disorder risk factor and
also the individual's individual
participants response from the first
round yeah so that they can look at how
they compare to the group opinion and
have a chance to change or even stay the
same depending on how they felt about
the opioid use risk factor
uh in the end ranking for all opioid
used uh disorder risk factor was
determined using the mean after the
final round
this is essentially a floor uh chart uh
just making a uh sharing that there were
some
of the participants that trapped after
the first round and I did make an
attempt to understand that there were
significant differences between the
responders and the non-responders so I
uh did uh statistical student if the if
the responders and non-responders
differed and I found that there was no
significant differences and except for
the professional training category where
we I did lose two naturopathic doctor in
the second round so that was just
important to know for my own uh you know
interpretation of of the results
and if you remember I did say that I
wanted to see if the experience has a an
impact on her on the consensus and the
ranking of the survey items and I found
that uh you know when I looked at the
responses from all level of experts and
compared that to just the responses from
level two and three experts the the
ranking did not shift a lot
um within one or two
places and uh and and so the consensus
was also not a very different
so the major results from this was what
I found was 34 oud risk factors from the
57 that I
um I use uh 32 34 or you do is Concepts
and factors reached consensus as very or
extremely useful
um free as moderately and one as not
useful the one that was not useful was
the genetic factor and providers in the
primary case setting uh really do not
know how to use that genetic data or
interpret that for the patient in front
of them a lot of thing is very
contextual most of the top ranking
concepts are also mentioned in the CDC
guidelines so that was good to know
aberrant drug related Behavior
constitute about half of the very
extremely useful consensus list followed
by substance use and pain and function
factors
so I'm looking at the open-ended
participant responses are I identified
additional information needs and
relevant Concepts involving social
support that are not specified in the
CDC guidelines many of the social
support constructs align with the
standard social determinants of Health
that are increasingly being collected in
the healthcare setting others however
are not typically assessed or recorded
like patient provider trust patient
activation and and patient self-efficacy
so here's a response from one of the
participant that kind of uh provides a
platform for um you know looking at the
data Readiness issue so he says uh that
while many of the items may be useful I
wouldn't trust our EHR to reliably
provide me that information and things
and things like personality disorder can
be long lasting chart law without any
actual documentation
um I also want to touch upon the
limitations how we didn't we did not add
new Concepts from the first round
um uh the the new Concepts that emerge
from the open response in um and do not
use it for the second round
the structure of the um and that was
done for the interest of time
the structure of the survey did not
allow for exploring relative importance
or ranking of oud risk factors and
Concepts when presented in combination
with other risk factors most
participants were from academic health
centers with strong culture for teaching
and research and so these findings may
not the findings from this effort or
this study may not be generalizable
so in conclusion there is a good
alignment between CDC guidelines and
Primary Care Providers as far as the top
risk factors for oud goes providers
consider social support factors in
determining oud risk for their patients
um which came out from this process
importance there's importance uh
importance of the latent constructs like
patient provided trust and patient and
self-efficacy that needs to be explored
further while aberrant drug related
Behavior seems to be most important
information domain for making oud risk
decisions that these are not
systematically collected in the EHR and
as a result there's a need to determine
the data Readiness of top ranked oud
Concepts and factors and uh think about
informatics
projects to address that
so here is my third question what does
accessibility and quality of Highly
useful oud concept and factors look like
in the EHR
and uh for this I uh it's a two-step
process again I uh did the
operationalization of each of the look
at the operationalization of each of
each of the high ranked oud risk factor
in the clinical setting so how may they
be used in the clinical setting and then
um mapped them to data standards and
variable and also used
developed a
use a quality assessment
of completion and correctness and
availability to assess the quality of
high ranked owerd risk factors to
determine data readiness
when I looked into literature for data
Readiness Frameworks this is what jumped
out one of the key papers more recent
papers which Define data Readiness as in
terms of quality availability
interoperability and provenance
however I started thinking what about
computability because computability is
required for learning health and system
and it's important for improving care
enabling research and informing policy
computable data are easy to extract for
secondary users and they're easy to
retrieve for display at the point of
care for calculating risk scores
so I made an attempt to Define
computability Within These elements and
so I decided the definability probably
is important uh structured field is
important and standard terminology tools
and code or code sets are important in
order for uh for a data to be computable
this is other data quality worksheet
that I used essentially you can see that
for each oud factor with in consultation
with the primary care provider I decided
um how they are documented and opera or
operationalized in the clinical setting
um whether they are present in the
structural field or not where where are
they present and if they are not present
present in the structured field could
they be structured could they be derived
from two or other structured field and
what are the omap codes for them is
there an Omar code or code set for each
of the oud risk factor
um and also looked at if there was a
standard instrument to collect that
oud concept or a factor
and the reason I used Omar codes are
it's it's a uh the Uma common data model
is a widely adopted uh common data model
and uh the vocabulary in this model is
uh fairly robust and it maps to a white
uh multiple clinical data standards and
that was a reason for me to select and
use Omar codes to see if you know there
were standard omark ports for each of my
OED risk factors
so these are the this was the high level
result uh basically identified that 10
of the 34 oud risk factors can be
determined as computable and mostly they
have structured field to collect them
and they had standard omark ports uh
potentially computable again as I said
that if they were collected using
standard tools
um and is there a way that a structured
field can be generated to capture that
if a standard tool was being used to
collect that in the in this in the
clinic
again can they be derived from a to a
more structured field some of them
required uh temporality to be
established so that may then potentially
uh computable
um there was a so 14 of them were
potentially computable that was the
largest group and then 10 were
non-computable
if you look at a one of the um just to
give you a sense like missing medical
appointment
uh need it needs to be defined further
it needs additional patient and practice
level context uh to Define uh and you
know and make it computable so how many
medical appointments a patient need to
miss in order for uh for him or her to
be flagged or how
um you know what kind of medical
appointments are they the same so that
gives you an idea about you know what
went into deciding needing further
definition
so when I followed my flowchart of uh
you know definability structure and
standards
um just to give you a high level results
as a 30 percent per computable as I
mentioned in the prior side 40 percent
potentially computable and 30 percent
um non-computable
um so um uh this now we reach the second
part of my aim uh aim three where I did
a data quality assessment of the top 10
computable oud factors and Concepts uh
in order to do that I developed a search
query for data extraction from the omap
instance of the associated Warehouse
here at OHSU for adult patients on
long-term opioid treatment for
non-cancer pain between January 2018 to
2019 and the reason for that time period
is the guidelines came out in 2016 and
it gave the enough time for uh some of
the practices to kind of formalize in
the clinic
I use the CDC guidelines
um sorry a quality improvement document
by the CDC to define the cohort and use
that for the uh for data extraction
strategy
uh so that was the data extraction
um uh part of it and and we also need it
I also needed to do chart review and so
I decided I would do for 30 patients on
long-term opioids
um uh to see how these Concepts uh the
10 computable Concepts appear in the in
their chart
the data quality and elements that were
used were correctness and completeness
as defined by the Hogan Hogan and
Wagner's method
so here's a two by two table essentially
Hogan and Vander defined uh completeness
and correctness using the sensitivity
and positive predictive value
measures
this is uh the result from this effort
as you see that alcohol use disorder has
a fairly High uh actually 100
sensitivity so what that the data that I
extracted for the 30 patients uh if
anybody had alcohol use disorder they
actually it did show up in the chart as
well so that was good uh so let's just
go over some of some of the major
findings from this so each highly useful
OED risk factor or concept was present
in at least not each Harry but each of
the 10 computable risk factor was
present in at least 10 or 20 percent of
the patients history of success use
disorder and showing symptoms consistent
consistent with opioid withdrawal are
present in almost 40 percent so that
this is that's a good you know that the
providers are actually documenting
history substance use disorder and
realizing it's a significant risk factor
um and it it had happened like it's
happening in the Phoenix uh patients
with current substance abuse disorder
were more likely to have history or
substance use disorder
um and so uh synthesizing the results
from from this effort was the even
though history of substance use disorder
and showing symptoms consistent with
opioid withdrawal were present in almost
40 percent of the patients uh and had a
data one had a greater sensitivity than
the other so history substance use
disorder was more likely to be complete
in both places in in data extract that I
extracted then um then the
the symptoms or withdrawal symptoms and
there's a reason for that providers are
more likely to check and document in the
problem list or as structured uh field
um data about history of substance use
as this is uh as I said is a highly uh
high risk factor for developing oud
however providers are less likely to
document signs of dependence and since
most of the patients who on extended use
do develop dependence on opioid use
on the prescription opioids
um so the second thing that jumped out
was establishing standard workflow for
collecting oud risk factor increases its
sensitivity or completeness so in the
clinics at OHSU we have a standard
workflow for collecting alcohol use data
which results in a better sensitivity
for this risk factor
PCP Champions uh primary care provided
Champions and local culture affects the
completeness of a uterus data providers
excuse me at ocsu Define hazardous
situation due to opioids as fall and
motor vehicle accident and this I found
while talking and Consulting primary
care provider here at Hsu as a result
fall and motor vehicle accident get
coded as a problem uh or as an encounter
hence increasing their availability and
completeness
um historical problems and those with
Associated stigma are less likely to be
captured in the structure here like
history of non-fatal Overdose Society
societal ideation and tense history of
targeted sexual abuse physical and
mental abuse though present in nearly 20
percent of the sample 30 patients that I
did the chart review on it has zero
sensitivity so that indicates even
though there are codes for this standard
codes it's and a structured field it
doesn't end up there
patients uh there is some really
Assurance though the patients with uh
will not be falsely flat for an oud risk
factor despite having high sensitivity
so high positive predictive value for
the following
um
oud risk factors like alcohol use
disorder or hazardous situation due to
opioid use history of substance use
disorder is a drug use uh they had
completely higher sensitivity but they
also have high level of correctness or
positive predictive value so that would
prevent them uh you know and any patient
was flagged at least is uh it clearly
has that that risk factor
uh have a limit their limitations
so the reasons for low completeness uh
could be due to in the extracted data
um could be due to incomplete standard
codes that's to extract the data and
there may be issues arising due to
temporality uh
finding may not be generalizable but I
do emphasize the methodology is so even
though this finding uh may not be
reflected in some other Healthcare
Center this methodology can be adopted
to understand information needs and
information Readiness Readiness gaps
using the manual chart review as a gold
standard was also a limitation because
we know that there is care fragmentation
and limited operability and that can you
know result in what we see in the chart
so in conclusion it is essential that
this factors and Concepts from oud are
findable and computable to meet the
triple aim of quality Care research and
policies this work is a novel attempt to
incorporate provider knowledge and
experience from The Real World practice
of oud risk assessment it provides a
framework for defining the gaps between
information needs and vendors for
complex condition with considerable
stigma this is a generalizable
methodology to prioritize informatics
efforts for standard and computable data
to enable learning health system and
evidence-based care which is not
currently available the work extends the
current data Readiness framework to
include computability as a construct
so the future work for the for this is
that result from this effort is we can
help prioritize future informatics
projects to get more or better data
especially improve completeness for
computable and potentially computable
data by
destigmatizing the problem establishing
standard workflow identifying provider
Champions and improving standard board
sets and also for the uh for
non-computable data there is a role that
NLP may play in retrieving that data to
the point of care
so I just wanted to close the loop on
where I started and how I entered my
original research question was uh why is
there a gap between guidelines and
practice and I found that part of this
Gap is due to the insufficient document
and I insufficient documentation so then
I asked uh in my aim too if the problem
is that the provider agrees with the
guidelines and determining order if the
if the provider agree with the
guidelines in determining OED risk and I
found that for the most part they do
though they I did Identify some
additional psychosocial factors that may
play a role in and the oud decision
making
so then knowing that provider agrees
with guidelines on high priority
Concepts I asked of the data available
for those concepts are sufficient for
the task and I found that often they are
not either they are not computable or
they are computable but incomplete
so um there is uh you know in spite of
all this they had this isn't a problem
about documentation or needed to or
needing to balance increased
documentation and provide a burden this
is a clinical space with a great deal of
stigma where patient provider trust is
extremely important this is a key
consideration in documentation practices
and not one that is present in many
common medical conditions methods to
address documentation insufficient
insufficiency and improve risk
prediction data availability at the
point of care and other use of data must
be informed by these challenges and so I
leave you with this final thought on my
work
I acknowledge my DAC Committee Member
and my research advisor for for her
great help and and believing in me Dr
Mary Pickett Dr Dana walbach and Dr
Steven Patrick my mentors Karen Eden
Jonathan Robbins Ben Sanders
Vishnu Mohan Aaron Cohen John Ash and
Steve kasaki and they've all shaped my
work
um demise students staff who've helped
me tremendously and special thanks to
Brian John the addiction medicine staff
fellows and faculty who gave me an
opportunity to sit in their didactic
conferences The Clinical Director is
here at otstu in the internal medicine
family medicine and centers for Women's
Health who helped me during the survey
process and the National Library of
Medicine of course for our for this
award
and I'm sorry I wanted to Also I ran you
know yeah thank my parents for nurturing
the spirituality and curiosity in me to
take this journey and complete it and my
family for their tremendous support
so much
questions
or just unsure your screen
this evening
chat let's see so maybe I'll ask a
question yeah
um thank you that um great talk
um I I sense in your conclusions a
little
for the right word I'll just say
ambivalence that's probably not the
right word but
um so it's like on the one hand
um there are possible solutions to
the data elements not being computable
that will help Drive decision support
practice Improvement
um on the other hand
um you found that clinicians take issue
with the guidelines you know so that you
um
you may come up with a really good
solution but you know will the
clinicians accept it so I guess my
question is
um
you know if you were going to pursue
this word further
um
what what would be your path and how
would you reconcile those
potentially conflicting
areas
yeah and thank you for for uh for uh
bringing to light the complexity about
the issue and uh and it makes
um even more sense uh for including the
provider Community when we are building
an informatic solution for this problem
um
any informatic solution needs to be
informed what's the real uh what the
real
um
uh
expectation or real
how is it going to be intent house is
going to be intended to be used in the
clinical career setting and uh whether
provider consider that it may cause some
harm to the patient or LA or not so
uh
helping uh making sure that uh
interventions uh do not cause harm to
the provider to the patients especially
due to the stigma around some of the
stigma being a huge issue it's very
essential that provider community and to
some extent patient community be
considered when we are developing uh
informative solution for data
availability for making real life
decisions
was there a relationship between a
computability of an element and its
frequency and the EHR like we're in
computable items more likely to be
present or was it more the quality of
items that people were documenting once
frequently
um
so
that's a good question
we do so we I think all of us are aware
of the copy and paste that happens uh so
once a thing is captured in the narrated
notes and it's a likelihood of it being
present in the negative note with a
greater frequency and the computable
items uh were as I said they had a
higher degree of positive predictive
values so they you know um
they were once they are captured in the
structure note you would find them
consistently still so it all depends uh
you know
what uh
how often those computable documents
were captured for them to be appearing
frequently if I'm if I understand your
question
[Music]
exactly
I'm not seeing any questions in the chat
okay when um we can we can leave you to
your committee yes
questions so thank you everyone for
attending and um
I also wanted to point out that today is
that
The Oaks day and uh so I just wanted to
draw attention to people attending this
to this uh this event
thank you
and I'll hang around here on the zoom
all right Mina
we'll need to stop recording
okay